[Música]
Uruguay vive en palabras del gobierno el
peor déficit hídrico desde que empezaron
a tomarse los registros Esto hace 74
años la preocupación crece en este país
de Sudamérica donde el agua sigue
agotándose y afectando por ejemplo el
sector agropecuario vamos a analizar
este tema y para ello saludamos en
Montevideo a Mario videgaín asesoro de
técnico de inumet meteorólogo máster en
ciencias de la atmósfera y especialista
en clima y en cambio climático Muchas
gracias a usted por estar en directo a
América Muchas gracias Buenos días
primero Cuál es la situación actual de
la sequía en Uruguay y cómo esto ha
afectado las reservas de agua en todo el
país
Bueno
estamos atravesando una sequía de más de
tres años tres años y medio
Prácticamente solo Uruguay y está
impactado fuertemente tanto en los
recursos de agua a nivel superficial
como también diríamos embalses este y
incluso agua para agricultura no agua a
nivel de suelo está sequía como bien tú
lo mencionabas ha sido la más importante
que hemos tenido estos últimos 74 años
esto lo muestran los registros que
tenemos por ejemplo a nivel de
Montevideo donde nunca hemos encontrado
una sequía de de más de tres años en
nuestro registro
Mario en el caso de Montevideo y el área
metropolitana se sabe que los ciudadanos
han manifestado haber sentido cierto
grado de salinidad en el agua A qué se
debe esto
claramente
la empresa del estado que abastece de
agua potable a toda la zona
metropolitana de Montevideo estamos
hablando de más de un millón y medio de
habitantes
en vista y en función de los bajos
caudales del río Santa Lucía que es la
fuente de agua potable para la zona
metropolitana ha comenzado a mezclar
diríamos lo que son aguas aguas arriba
diríamos agua dulce proveniente de río
Santa Lucía con aguas abajo provenientes
del río de la plata el río de la plata
Que
para los que no saben es un estuario
digo que tiene mezcla con agua oceánicas
por lo tanto tiene cierto grado de
salinidad en esta mezcla entonces lo que
se hace es aumentar En definitiva la
salinidad del agua potable con la panza
de abastece a Montevideo mire y esto
tiene algún efecto en la salud de los
ciudadanos
bueno el misterio de salud pública a
nivel de Uruguay ha emitido algunas
consideraciones y alertas por ejemplo
para personas con hipertensión y también
para la que sería alimentación de
bebés con las fórmulas Que obviamente es
necesario disolver en en agua para no
utilizar agua potable sino agua
embotellada con menores niveles de
salinidad bueno mire quisiera
preguntarle si este problema aparte del
evidente problema que hay a nivel
mundial por cambio climático acelerado
tiene que ver con la falta de gestión de
las aguas residuales si se podría hacer
más en términos de reutilización del
agua y de nuestros productos pues para
que esto no siguiera pasando O al menos
no en niveles tan extremos como el que
estamos viendo en Uruguay
Sí aquí hay dos diríamos dos vías que
Uruguay todavía no ha utilizado uno
sería como bien tú mencionas el
reciclaje de agua las aguas servidas
esto es usual en algunas naciones he
vivido en Madrid por ejemplo Madrid en
España recicla gran parte de esa agua
para volver la potabilizar eso no es no
se utiliza en Uruguay digo porque
tradicionalmente ha habido una
abundancia de agua dulce y no es
necesario esa medida la otra medida que
tampoco se ha tomado hasta el momento es
la desalinización
recientemente el gobierno justamente
incorporado ha comprado dos plantas de
salinización para justamente bajar los
niveles de salinidad en el agua potable
pues repito entonces Esas son dos vías
que actualmente Uruguay por lo menos
hasta el momento no se han no se han
explorado bueno entre tanto hay que
resolver digamos lo inmediato y ahí le
quiero preguntar Cuáles son esas
regiones del país que se han visto más
afectadas por la situación y sobre todo
A qué industrias han golpeado con mayor
medida
bueno esta sequía digo que es una sequía
que no solo ha afectado Uruguay hasta se
queda que ya cumple tres años y medio no
solo afectado a Uruguay sino también
afectado a Argentina lo que sería el
este Argentina sur de Brasil o sea es
una sequía regional que abarca más que
la extensión propiamente de Uruguay y
diríamos en el proceso de estos tres
años y medio se ha visto que la zona más
afeitada por lo menos en Uruguay ya ha
sido suroeste y sur del país justamente
Donde está ubicado la Cuenca del río
Santa Lucía que abastece de agua al
océano metropolitana esto no no tenía
precedentes porque normalmente la sequía
que hemos padecido en episodios
anteriores nuevamente afectaban más el
extremo norte de nuestro país O sea lo
que sería la frontera con Brasil pero en
este en este evento repito de más de
tres años sequía y por lo menos en este
último periodo este último año son las
más afectadas repito ha sido el extremo
sur del país lo que sería lindero o
litoral del río de la plata bueno y
quería preguntarle también que tanto
recae la responsabilidad en el ciudadano
de a pie Y si las comunidades de
conservación tienen un papel ahí en un
uso responsable del agua Pues en medio
de esta crisis o es algo más que atañe a
las compañías y al estado
no yo creo que es muy importante lo que
tú mencionas de hoy de que el ciudadano
de a pie también tiene que tomar en
primera instancia conciencia de que el
agua no es un elemento infinito o sea es
un elemento finito y por lo tanto
podemos tener episodios como estos donde
haya una falta importante de este
recurso de acuerdo a la variabilidad
climática y digamos en estas últimas
semanas a nivel de gobierno se ha hecho
ya comenzado en la campaña de
concientización para el uso responsable
del agua y Está marcado que en estas
últimas semanas hemos tenido un descenso
en el consumo de agua de alrededor de un
10% creo que esto hay que todavía
promoverlo aún más y diríamos racional
de una de una manera voluntaria lo que
serían los el acceso al agua potable
bueno Y finalmente Qué opinión le merece
a usted el gran aumento del consumo de
agua embotellada porque esto tiene otros
efectos y otros problemas para no ir más
lejos Pues la contaminación por plástico
y el microplástico que se está
consumiendo
exactamente digo El problema del acceso
a agua potable de calidad disparado
digamos los que son los consumos de agua
embotellada agua mineral con los
problemas como bien tú mencionás no un
problema también de acceso porque
digamos no toda la población Puede
acceder a este a este elemento no agua
embotellada por debido a los costos y
también como tú mencionas el impacto que
se produce sobre el medio ambiente por
los plásticos que en general por lo
menos el caso de Uruguay es difícil de
digamos reciclar por lo menos a nivel de
del país Entonces digamos tenemos un
Doble Impacto en impacto económico por a
nivel de de la población de escasos
recursos y por otro lado el impacto así
a nivel ambiental por el exceso de
plástico en el ambiente Pues bien es
Mario videgaín asesor técnico de inumed
meteorólogo y también especialista en
clima en cambio climático Mario Muchas
gracias a usted Por favor un gusto
continuamos nosotros en directo América
ya volvemos con más
[Música]